[Music]
all right let's go to sherry in
brooktondale new york what's up sherry
hi dr zolone what are you up to um
work
what kind of work do you do
i'm i'm a registered nurse
oh you've had a boring few years
yeah right
how are you for real
good good
good good that's tough that's tough
tough tough and in new york nonetheless
good grief yeah
geez all right so what's up how can i
help
so my
my question or concern is i have um i
i'm naturally an anxious person um but
when i'm in a vehicle with somebody else
especially as a passenger
um my anxiety is through the roof
um
natural you know back roads i do fine
with
um but high traffic situations
um
you know stopping
like when there's a lot of traffic
around traffic lights um the highway is
the worst um
even with my husbands we've been married
for um almost
um i think 27 years and my anxiety i
used to be pretty cool about things and
it's just gotten it's terrible the last
couple years
did something did something happen to
set it off
no
i mean not not really maybe i'm gonna
say 20 years ago
i
i was following somebody a friend and i
were you know in a vehicle and
um
she had pointed out to me that the car
in front of us was swerving a little bit
and the car actually in front of me went
over a yellow line and was hit head-on
by a
tractor-trailer and then the
tractor-trailer came in front of me
um so i luckily i had backed off or i
think i would have we would have been
you know in that accident
um okay so you're just telling me that
yeah does your heart start beating
faster
yeah i could your voice changed a little
bit
oh okay
when you talk about that story you tell
somebody that story you remember that
story
yes yeah pretty much deep detail for
detail you can feel it on you right
yeah okay all right so yep then all of a
sudden the last couple of years this
pops up um is this getting into the way
of your life
i know that sounds like a dumb question
but i mean you could just
a simple answer people just don't drive
on the highway um tell me where this is
getting involved this is messing your
life up a little bit
it is it is my husband and i are to the
point now where
we're arguing in the car and he's like
and he's a he's a school bus driver so
he's
he does this for a living oh there's
nothing
nothing that husbands like more
um when they have they're good at like
two things in the world
and their wife is like you know what you
should be doing
my boys i have two sons who
you know i
was helping them with their getting
their driver's license and so i was
often in the back seat because i'm the
obnoxious worried mom
um and i tried my best to keep my mouth
shut but still so literally a backstreet
driver yes i i am no matter who
no matter who who it is
and i'm not saying this to shame you i'm
saying this just as a fact
that creates then
how many boys you got
i have two okay
that creates a legacy of anxious drivers
that they will then pass on to do you
see how that goes
yep right and i know you know that i
know that's one of the reasons why you
wanna
so two two big things here
um i'll start off with a question that i
always ask people who are wrestling with
um intense anxiety like this especially
one that's escalating
um that's seemingly getting worse over
time okay
and this sounds like a i'm making fun of
you with this question and i'm not i'm
deeply serious about this question and i
think it's where every single person
struggling with anxiety should start
and that is do you want to be free of
this
or is this serving a purpose in your
life that you want to hang on to
no there's there's no purpose it needs
to it needs to go okay okay it needs to
go sometimes when somebody uh maybe
they've been assaulted or um they've got
some sort of existential fear about
being alone with with a man right
they'll tell me when they're in the
presence of any man
the good guys neutral guys guys they've
never met their bodies
sounds the alarms right their heart
starts being a little bit faster their
hands get clammy they get that warmth in
their stomach that that fear response
kicks up
and they don't want to let that go
because there's this perception that
that's keeping me safe it's not but it
it feels like a defense like a
protective layer that i don't want to
give up
and so i always ask people uh and that's
you can extrapolate that across anything
i always ask do you want this to be done
so you want to be you want do you want
this completely done with you want to be
able to hop in a car drive on the
highway ride on the highway kick your
feet up laugh
absolutely yes that is what i want okay
so um here's two two ways we're gonna
approach this
this isn't every situation but this is
your situation i think this is a great
place for most people to start
um first is you have an acute situation
you were almost killed in in a car on
the highway
okay and so
the word i use there is ownership you
have to own that almost happened to you
you have to own that when you get on a
highway
you are turning over your life to
thousands of other strangers going in
the same direction opposite directions
for you and any one of them
can move their wheel one inch
and kill you
you have to just own that yeah and it
almost happened to you right
yep so a big thing about our anxiety is
it
builds this big fake wall in front of
reality
and so one of the cornerstones of
getting well from anxiety is saying this
could happen and for you it almost did
and your body put a gps pin you know
when you tell somebody where to be in
that little it's almost a heart shape
but it's not quite
it's a little gps pin your body put a
pin in that
and said this situation is not safe
just as though 10 000 years ago you were
walking through the woods and you saw
bear cha-cha on the ground and your body
put a pin in that and said this area is
not safe because this is where the bears
are let's go find food somewhere else
same
same neurological mechanism at work here
it put a pen in highways and said not
safe but life happens
and we are really good at coming up with
distractions and duct tape and figuring
out other ways to get through life so
we get angry we get raged out we white
knuckle it we have another drink another
drink we cheat we come up with
distractions for ourselves and we can
distract ourselves for five years ten
years fifteen twenty years and then
what'd you say your job was you're a
nurse
yeah yeah the last two years have been
utter hell right
oh for for sure and i drive i drive a
lot i'm i work with you know um
developmentally disabled people in group
homes and i have to drive a long ways to
get to my
work okay
so what you have
is a
you've heard of the phrase secondary
traumatic stress
yep you live in other people's pain for
a living that's what you do you provide
you provide hope and light
and connectivity to people in the
darkest moments people who are alone and
isolated with disabilities
that's what you do and you do that over
time and your body begins to shift how
it sees the world that everything is
pretty dark and pretty messy and then
you throw a pandemic in on top of it and
the normal things that keep us well and
whole like human connection like
exercise like sunlight like good sleep
suddenly goes away
and
all anxiety is is an alarm system
letting you know that you're not safe
you're disconnected or you're in a
situation where you can't control and
quite honestly when you're on the
highway
we're as safe as we could be driving
down the highway in two thousand pound
metal boxes at seven or eighty miles an
hour
there is little control we have over
what our neighbors are going to do on
the roads we can only control ourselves
and so two out of the three things there
are already on the table for our little
primitive brains that are trying to
adapt from riding a horse to suddenly
driving down the road in a volkswagen
right
so when the rest of your coping
mechanisms have gotten thin over the
last few years it doesn't surprise me in
the least in fact it makes perfect sense
that the alarms about the highway have
gotten louder and louder and louder
that's just a distraction from
the what the broader picture which is
you're not you're not okay you're tired
you're exhausted
your relationships are
messy and my guess is you got teenage
boys now is that right
uh one's 22 and the other is 19. oh see
now you're starting to have pictures of
your life when they're not in them
and they're going off to do their things
right
and yeah it was very hard when they
first got their licenses very hard but
it's hard because you lose that sense of
control right now they're off in the
world but also it's a transition my
little boy's growing up
and that means my life is gonna be
different you see what i'm saying
like it shifts and so what your body's
feeling is this ultimate everything's
starting to move on us the boys are
going to college they're going to move
away i'm going to have to look at this
husband of mine and go ugh
what are we gonna do now and he's just a
bus driver and you're like turn left
turn right and we're gonna have to
figure out who we are
and so here's what i want you to do i
want you to do two important things
moving forward okay
yeah this is gonna sound ridiculous
actually three all right three things
first one is
i want you to write a letter
to the family the imaginary family that
died in that car wreck 20 years ago
okay
yeah i want you to imagine a name for
them tell them that you're sorry that
they died in the car
that um
you know they had hopes and dreams and
that they are gone
and you never met them but you miss them
and you're sorry that that happened
and what we're doing there is we're
connecting the fight-or-flight part of
your brain to
[Music]
right now
you weren't safe then you're safe now
and what we're trying to do over time is
to calm that part down that every time
you get in a car
the second thing is
when you get in the car
it would probably be good honestly if
you wrote your 20 year old 20 year past
self a letter too
that acknowledges we almost died
right so dear sherry 20 years ago we
were driving on the road man if it
wasn't for one phone call we would have
been dead
but we made it and we're okay
and that was scary right i want you and
what we're doing is we're just letting
our bodies
acknowledge that happened but we're okay
now
and then the third the second thing is i
want you to begin to look at what are
the alarms telling you
about your current ecosystem
are you exhausted when's the last time
you exercised how's your diet how is
your marriage when's the how what's your
sex life like your intimacy life
are you and your husband um pulling
apart are y'all coming together how are
you grieving the loss of your boys
their childhoodness now they're adults
right
um they're gonna start kissing girl a
growth right whatever's gonna happen is
gonna start happening you gotta start
acknowledging that stuff and i want you
to be honest about it and find somebody
you can tell if you and your husband
have a great relationship that could be
a great place
and when i've seen this done it's a
teary sob sobbing mess
because our bodies have been trying to
solve for these things but our heads are
just all right gotta go the next meeting
gotta go the next thing gotta go to
little league
and our bodies are trying to solve for
this over and over and over and over
again while our heads are just trying to
stay in the game
and then the third thing is you have to
be honest about
your job
that secondary traumatic stress i had to
transition from one job to another when
i was healing from anxiety
we took a massive household income pay
cut to do it
i had to go work with a smaller group of
students i still did the same job i just
did it with 500 students instead of 4
000
and that allowed me
over time to heal up
and i had to start serving my local
community had to do some different
things i don't know what that's going to
be for you
i've also had seasons when i'm super
anxious and i kept my same job and
things were fine i just had to be
intentional about my boundaries at work
and not taking everything and i can't
control all this stuff right
ultimately
oh and here's the fourth one you're
gonna have to decide to get on the road
and acknowledge it every time you get in
the car for a season i'm about to get in
the car and i'm gonna drive safe
and that's the best i can do
okay
and when your body starts to get anxious
on you before you flip out
ask yourself what are we nervous about
right now
like what's my body trying to tell me
that we're going 90 miles an hour in a
little square kia yeah that's pretty
terrifying
but i got it
you see what i'm doing i'm taking the
i'm taking the gas out of that that
anxiety engine
why why is my body doing this oh because
that guy's driving like a [ __ ] i'm
gonna back 10 miles an hour off or i'm
going to speed up 10 miles an hour and
pass them because i don't want to be in
the vicinity of that person
oh man every time i see a tractor
trailer my heart starts beating really
fast i'm just going to get curious and
i'm going to stop going to war with my
body tell me if i'm wrong
now you've gotten to a point where when
y'all have to go somewhere you get
anxious about the fact that you're going
to get anxious
yeah yep yep it's
yes
we we have a trip planned and we decided
to fly because my husband nor i could
handle the drive it would be a disaster
so
ah awesome
it could have been a good time but let's
fly on this one
and then let's start practicing and this
is gonna sound silly but i want you to
tell your husband um hey saturday we're
just gonna go to a 30-minute drive on
the highway and i'm gonna practice
saying nothing
i'm gonna practice
loosening the grip on the steering wheel
or i'm gonna not grab the little door
handle while you're driving right
the emergency brake that doesn't exist
exactly
i'm gonna put my feet up on the
dashboard with no shoes
and i'm gonna paint my toenails while
you drive
i'm going to phil
oh boy what we're doing here practice
we're just practicing not being anxious
and
in short order your body will begin to
realize oh she's driving now we don't
have to run this thing from the fight or
flight anymore because sherry's in
control
we're here when you need us the next
time some idiot drives crazy which they
will we're ready
we're ready we'll flood you full of
adrenaline and cortisol and we'll help
you think move a little bit faster than
your brain's even thinking but until
then sherry's got this
and it's a choice i'm going to decide to
be less anxious over time i'm going to
be curious about it when my alarms go
off
and if you're honest with yourself those
anxiety alarms go off
more so than when you're in the car
my guess is they're going off a lot
that's just a place where there's a gps
pin in your life
and it it's easy to go oh that's where
it is my guess is
there's a disconnect with your boys this
is a time of transition for your
marriage this is a time of exhaustion
from work this is a global mess we're
all dealing with it's expensive to buy
gas all those things are happening and
my guess is your anxiety alarms are
running across the board right now as
they are in lots and lots and lots and
lots of us
and it's just easy to point at the
driving that's where all surfaces that's
the volcano but it's been turning
underneath all that so what we're going
to do is we're going to work to have a
life that goes
the only word i can say here that
doesn't sound cheesy is peace
i was gonna sleep
we're gonna get our sex life back we're
gonna start eating better we're gonna go
for walks in the evening or in the
mornings
peace
and then your body will stop selling the
alarms just willy-nilly
and then finally
you won't hassle him about the turn
signal
let the guy drive